you've had this blessed career you've
had so many fantastic roles you really
seem to relish what you do you enjoy it
and you've had these parts come your way
and some of them must have seemed like
that's not a good idea like for example
when they come to you with big lebowski
and you think of all the other great
iconic roles you've played did you know
right away that's a great movie did you
think this is going to be good
i'll tell you what on that one it was
tough i read the script i loved the
script
but i'm playing you know this pothead
guy you know and not that i had anything
against potheads right but yeah let's
just get that out there yeah
jeff bridges has nothing against
potheads
[Applause]
man but i'm the kid of a famous guy you
know lloyd bridges
you know you remember that of course of
course one of the great and so i know
there's kind of a downside to being the
kid of a famous person yeah because
there's a lot of baggage and people
think you know
so i thought you know i don't know how
my my girls i had three young girls at
that time and how they were going to
feel you know they were going to get
teased or how they would feel about that
right so i put a dot to them i said you
know this is like he's into you know
smokes you know drugs these are
absolutely you're asking you're asking
your kids should i play this person get
permission kind of you know for my wife
and my kids wow i never asked permission
for anything that i do on i've been my
entire career they would say don't do
that you'll look like an ass so no i've
never done anything but you that's what
i that's when i was i was you know
and the pause you know and then my
middle girl jesse said dad
you're an actor
it's pretend you know we know that you
play you know when you kiss uh you know
other women on the films we know that
you still love mom so go for it go do it
good for her that's how we get i'm glad
she said yes
it is such an iconic film that there's
something called lebowski fest it's a
two-day festival
where fans dress up
as the characters in the movie and they
go bowling and there's parties and they
watch the movie we actually have this is
a still from lebowski festival and
yeah it's just like
i'm curious
have you been to lebowski i have played
a lebowski fest my band the abiders
you know harold yes he abides the dude
abides we uh we played the lebowski fest
and it was sort of my beatles moment you
know i mean and now the dude and i come
out and i rock with these to a sea of
dudes really they're all dressed up
but you've got in the audience you have
bowling pins uh you know the more
bizarre outfit there was one guy
who dressed up like the drawing i don't
know this is a bizarre reference to the
movie but right to the drawing that
jackie treehorn
does and the dude takes that one guy was
dressed up like that guy with the best
you have you have people that are going
so deep and for you to go to that event
you would be the ultimate god what a
great feeling it was wild we just had a
wild time yeah amazing